foreign
welcome to next 2022 I'm Jordan Hamilton
a Staff Solutions architect focused on
cloud bigtable
I'm akshita a software engineer at box
and today we'll be hearing about box and
their modernization Journey from an
on-prem nosql database to Cloud bigtable
today we'll be covering a brief intro on
bigtable and modernization patterns then
we'll hand it over to akshata where she
will share more about Box's exciting
journey and cover why they chose
bigtable insights on migrations and
review where they are at today with
their production workloads on bigtable
then we'll wrap it up with available
migration tools and what's next
before we learn about boxes
modernization let's first review
bigtable with a high level overview of
what it is and why it's a common key
value store for production workloads and
modernization
Google has had to deal with a lot of
data considering its mission statement
and its many consumer products it needed
petabyte scale capacity to store the
data that was continually evolving and
changing schema over time
if you think about some of the use cases
at Google and the data it had to store
you're likely thinking about electronic
messages or email geographic information
URL contents and per user data all that
required High volumes and extremely fast
access
Google developed bigtable in 2004 to
handle both the scale and precision
accuracy needed it was then released to
production in 2005 and the paper came
out a year later
bigtable the same big table that we made
available to our Cloud customers in 2015
is really behind several of the billion
user consumer services that you may use
today with search analytics maps and
Gmail
bigtable continues to grow and has more
than 10 exabytes of data under
management and serves over 5 billion
queries per second it's a fully managed
key value database and our average Cloud
customers who are coming from on-prem or
other clouds are achieving stable
performance with millisecond latencies
and millions millions of queries per
second
bigtable fully Embraces Open Source by
providing an open API with Apache hbase
making it open source friendly and
workload portable
many of the open source distributed
systems that you may be familiar with
are modeled off of Technologies
innovated at Google specifically with
open source nosql databases actually a
family tree of them true inspiration
from bigtable and were developed and
began surfacing in 2008. this included
the release of Apache hbase along with
Apache Cassandra and Apache accumulo
which was developed by the NSA
all of these key value databases have
workloads that are built on nosql and
these use cases are usually a good fit
for bigtable
the next place where bigtable really
comes up today where box will talk a lot
more about our migrations and
modernizing nosql workloads with
bigtable
we're seeing many migrations to Cloud
bigtable come from hbase and Cassandra
today although we have supported
migrations from other databases
including dynamodb Cosmos DB and even
MySQL and Oracle bigtable is a great fit
for workloads that are key value like
queries with a single row of data or a
range of rows it is also good with white
column and time series which are used
use cases over the common these common
sources
of these common sources let's take a
closer look at hbase and what we're
seeing with modernizations
it's common to see hbase deployed as
part of a distributed ecosystem as it
provides integration with services like
Kafka mapreduce spark spark SQL for
streaming querying and batch processing
hbase can be co-deployed within a data
Lake that shares resources within a
cluster or deployed as a standalone
nosql database for an application or
service
with minimal changes we're seeing the
stack transform with applications and
services remaining in place and the
underlying storage and databases being
decoupled
Cloud bigtable provides integration with
existing applications and services
provides data compatibility for
migrating raw bytes from one to the
other and has minimal changes for
namespaces if they're in use
this integration is really great it
allows us to not have to rewrite our
applications and we can get started with
using bigtable and take advantage of
multi-cluster deployments running on
Google's dedicated networks which is
quite complex to set up with hbase
further as we move into the Google
ecosystem you may continue to run your
existing applications and clients with
bigtable or you may use a native client
Library based on your favorite language
there are also several other Google
cloud services such as bigquery SQL on
bigtable with Federated queries called
dataproc for running open source
software including Apache spark dataflow
for managed pipelines in a rich
integration with the beam SDK and
tensorflow for training with ML models
on data stored in bigtable
next without further Ado let's have
akshata take us through boxes
modernization Journey thanks Jordan
hi again let me start with an intro to
box box is a Content Cloud it enables
users to securely create share co-edit
and retain their content online
box is in the process of moving its core
infrastructure from on-prem data centers
to cloud and today I'm going to talk
about how we migrated our nosql
infrastructure to Cloud bigtable
let's take a look at a couple of nosql
use cases at box
specifically the ones which are in the
critical path of every user request
these have latency requirements in the
order of tens of milliseconds first the
storage service this service is
responsible for storing every file
uploaded to box in specific regions
based on the data residency requirements
that on the file
metadata like location size Etc are
stored in a nosql table and accessed at
every download
this table is about 150 terabytes in
size and spans over 600 billion rows
a second example is the key encryption
service it encrypts every file uploaded
to box with a unique encryption key it
stores these encryption keys in a nosql
table which is about 80 terabytes in
size and spans over 200 billion rows
both the services perform operations
like check inputs gets and deletes and
were hosted on HP is running in box data
centers
so why did we go with bigtable firstly
it takes away the operational burden of
managing the infrastructure ourselves
secondly bigtable provides automatic
replication with eventual consistency
which is quite similar to hbase next
bigtable provides an hbase compliant
Library which means that we could
migrate away from each base with minimal
code changes
also scaling a bigtable cluster is
effortless and can be achieved in a
matter of minutes
finally bigtable offers managed backup
and restore features which are Super
convenient and also essential for our
critical data
let's look at some choices we made with
bigtable configuration
first decision was for storage type
here there are two options SSD and HDD
SSD is faster than HDD but more
expensive
to help guide the decision we ran some
performance tests that simulated our
traffic patterns on both SSD and HDD
clusters we found that latencies from
SSD clusters were more in line with our
performance requirements and that's what
we went with
the next decision was for the number of
clusters bigtable allows up to eight
replicated clusters in an instance
having two clusters in a multi-region
instance already offers four nines of
availability which was deemed sufficient
for our use cases
so we went with the two cluster setup
for comparison though we used a three
cluster HP setup to achieve similar
availability
next for routing we had to decide
whether to rely on the automatic
multi-cluster routing or go with single
cluster routing and handle failover
ourselves we had to go with single
cluster routing here because the use of
conditional rights in our applications
was incompatible with multi-cluster
routing
now let's look at the actual migration
process given the critical nature of our
services this needed to be a zero
downtime migration that is we had to
migrate without disrupting user traffic
and without affecting latencies
first we perform reads and writes to
both bigtable and hbase the bigtable
reads and writes here are asynchronous
and best effort this allows us to
Monitor bigtable latencies and tune its
settings without impacting any user
traffic second after we stabilize the
bigtable metrics we switch to
synchronous bigtable reads and writes
this effectively brings bigtable in the
critical path of the user traffic and
this allows us to achieve consistency
between bigtable and age base for all
the newly written data
we learned some interesting lessons from
this phase of migration first
performance testing is worth it the
throughput numbers published by Cloud
providers are highly dependent on the
workload type so we evaluated big table
performance under box workloads as the
very first step this not only gave us
confidence to proceed with bigtable
migration but also informed our
configuration choices like the use of
SSD for example
second final conditional rights with
care
the use of conditional Rights was
incompatible with bigtables
multi-cluster failover routing so we had
to implement our own automatic failover
logic for certain failure scenarios to
support our conditional rights without
impacting availability
it's also interesting to note that
conditional rights May reduce the
throughput you can derive from the
cluster and that's a good reason to
include them in performance tests Beyond
just plain puts and gets
lastly good debug tools are
indispensable we discovered a few
helpful gcp tools in the course of
fine-tuning the bigtable metrics for
example stackdriver tracing provides
traces with detailed latency insights at
every step of the request and the key
visualizer helps isolate hot spots in
the bigtable key space
in Phase 2 we perform backfill of old
data from hbase to bigtable and run a
series of validations to ensure that the
data is consistent
let's zoom into each of these next
backfill involves three steps first we
take a snapshot of the table on each
base
second we write the snapshot files to a
GCS bucket for this we used hps's export
snapshot job in conjunction with
Google's open sourced GCS connector
finally we load data from GCS into
bigtable using a data proc job this job
is also open sourced by Google
now let's look at our validation
strategies closely
we had to validate both the ongoing
traffic as well as the old backfill data
to do these validations we first built
logic in our services to compare the
read results between each base and
bigtable the results were then carefully
categorized into different types and
emitted as metrics and logs for ongoing
traffic this comparison logic was
triggered as users accessed our services
for backfill data we triggered the
comparisons explicitly using an internal
service that iterates over random key
ranges
after analyzing the validation metrics
and logs we found that most of the
mismatches were expected or explainable
and gave a sufficient confidence in the
consistency of data between hbase and
bigtable
we run some interesting lessons from
this phase of migration too first we had
lots of fine-grained metrics to track
everything in each base and bigtable
this was super useful in comparing the
system side by side to validate
performance as well as correctness
second storage utilization on each base
and bigtable can vary depending on the
compression type in our case we had to
account for additional storage usage on
bigtable during the backfill process
now we arrive at the final phase of the
migration here we switch to bigtable as
a source of truth but we continue to
write to both hpace and bigtable in case
we need a rollback
after running in the state for a while
and having gained sufficient confidence
in the new stack we finally cut ties
with hbase
so where are we at now
we no longer need manual interventions
by sres to scale our clusters and that's
been a huge operational relief
we see around 80 millisecond latencies
to big table from our on-prem services
we see sub 20 millisecond latencies from
our gcp resident services especially
when bigtable cluster is in the same
region
finally most of our big nosql use cases
have been migrated to bigtable and I'm
happy to report that some have been
successfully running for over a year now
with that I'd like to hand it back over
to Jordan
thank you akshata next let's review some
available migration capabilities to
accelerate your migration
first let's quickly review the bigtable
hbase client Library the one that box
used in production to send reads and
writes that were previously sent to
hbase to bigtable as depicted in the
diagram here
the library supports hbase 1.x and 2.x
clients and may be added to your
application in the Java build or as an
auxiliary jar the library can then be
configured to send requests to bigtable
and the
hbasesite.xml or in the application
configuration properties
I won't go through the details here but
here are the artifacts for the client
Library you'll want to add one of these
artifacts artifact options to your
existing application to include the
library
next here's an example for configuring
the library to send requests to bigtable
authentication may be set up here using
a Google service account by configuring
the property with
google.bigtable.auth Json key file or
setting the Google application
credentials environmental variable
next let's review tooling for migration
approaches whether you're able to take
down time for a migration that's offline
as depicted here on the left or require
a zero downtime for your migration
similar to box with a live migration as
on the right we now have a set of tools
to help simplify and accelerate
migrations
we start with offline migration tools
that include the schema translator tool
to automate table creation on bigtable
with split points from the hbase table
ddls a snapshot import job to batch load
the data and lastly validation tools to
provide byte level comparison
for live migrations we require the same
set of tools but also require a method
to propagate changes while the
historical data is being migrated there
are a few options listed here and of
them we have recently released two tools
to provide a solution for live
migrations
the first is a dual client called the
mirroring client library and the second
extends hbases replication service to
replicate changes from hbase to Cloud
bigtable
the bigtable mirroring client library is
similar to the live migration solution
that box had used for its zero downtime
migration
you can follow the same sequence of
steps as their migration with this
Library
and it provides three configuration
modes for mirroring rights with the
asynchronous sequential rights where
rights are first committed to hbase and
upon success asynchronously written to
bigtable
the second mode is synchronous
sequential rights and the third
configuration is synchronous concurrent
rights
it also provides read verification and
the ability to specify a fraction of the
reads to be replayed on bigtable to
verify consistency
with the next live migration option we
provide a library that extends the hbase
replication endpoint and can enable peer
replication which is normally used to
replicate from one cluster hbase cluster
to another but now can replicate to
bigtable
this approach does not require dual
rights which may be prone to consistency
issues but does require the library to
be installed on either the production
hbase cluster or a sidecar hbase cluster
that is dedicated just for replicating
to bigtable
this library is installed on hbase
cluster and can be enabled with the
hbase shell
let's wrap up and cover next steps
you can find more information about
migrations in our public docs and the
links below we also have a code lab for
walking through migrating to bigtable
and finally with features and
capabilities we're looking to help
customers build Advanced topologies they
may require across clouds in on-prem
we're also looking at bi-directional
sync with big table changes change
streams which is coming soon
lastly we're continuously looking at
minimizing migration differences with
hbase and are underway with introducing
big table reverse scans early next year
subject to change with this we're
looking to make migrations easier and
more compatible
thank you akshita and thank you all for
joining us here today thank you
[Music]